- The reason why there's
such division, right now,
is because people want
people to go for the jugular,
and because people, you know,
are like, okay don't talk about it.
It's either under rug swept,
or it's just cut 'em at the throat.
Like and it's like,
the reason why that
division, I feel exists,
is because we're not focused
on the real root of the issues,
and instead of just
talking about something
that is right there
that we can all talk about and
all join in the conversation,
and all feel like you're
a part of it, like,
instead of doing that,
which is what I feel like your film did,
everybody always wants to make some expose
that just murders people, and
it's like, that's not working.
Like, that kind of
mentality isn't working.
- Hey man, I did it for a living!
I did it, you know.
- But it's not working right now, like-
- No, I don't think it is.
- Fight people with that kind of,
you're not going to win at this point.
Everybody keeps trying to do
that, and it's not working.
- Right. Well it's permanent, also,
we never get a break, you know,
What I realized is, to some extent,
we as a country need makeup sex,
and I think when you're in
a permanent election cycle-
- [Kelly] Don't we all? (laughing)
- Yeah, the permanent election cycle,
really does set those
divisions in concrete.
You never get a chance to
take off your team jersey,
and kind of see people for who they are.
And it's why, in this moment, I feel like,
there's something important
happening, is that...
nobody likes to get called
out on their (beep),
and I'm, you know, I always
had a terrible problem
of being very defensive
about things like that,
and I worked really hard to
try to be less that, but...
it's a moment where we
might have a chance,
to see each other.
It's gonna be a hard conversation,
and it's going to take, you know,
truth and reconciliation,
is a really difficult
place to be in a society,
but if we don't address this,
truly gaping, open wound,
it won't ever heal,
and we can pretend that,
we're supposed to have two Americas,
but we're really not.
It's okay, we're not all
supposed to get along
and hold hands,
and there will be real divisions,
and real challenges, and real issues.